hello and welcome my name is amir abbas
i'm a product manager at google i focus
on application and platform
modernization
last year i delivered a presentation
with an eerily similar topic to this one
it was called building globally scalable
applications with istio and antho
service mesh so you're probably
wondering why am i doing the same
presentation again well not quite i
thought this year i would take some of
the foundations and principles we talked
about last year and put them into
practice and i can show you some of the
practical applications of delivering
modern applications so let's get started
let's talk about a service everything
revolves around a service we build our
teams our organizations our engineering
our product teams to deliver beautiful
scalable resilient services to our
customers every service needs a few
things for instance the service needs to
be resilient it needs to be scalable it
needs to be secure and most importantly
needs to be manageable and what we mean
by that is by resiliency i mean that we
need to be able to weather the storms
against any infrastructure human or
machine error
scalability is pretty self-explanatory
we need to be able to run our services
on many computers maybe in many
kubernetes clusters in a lot of
different zones in many regions
for security we want to encrypt all
traffic all communication between
services and we want to be able to have
the tools to implement policy and
enforce policy to and from every single
service
and for manageability there's a lot of
things that fall under that umbrella
for instance what do we want to observe
how do we want to measure the signals
how do we deliver traffic to the right
instance of a service and how do we
reliably roll out new versions of a
service and keep innovating and manage
the configuration that revolves around a
service all of that falls under
manageability
so let's recap last year we talked about
running services in a single cluster
here we have a service called frontend
running in the front-end namespace with
a pod and it's running in a single
cluster and everything is fine and dandy
until that cluster goes down and as soon
as that cluster goes down that service
and any other service that's running in
that cluster also goes down with it so
we've kind of broken that first first
tenet of resiliency which is that we
can't even weather the storms against
infrastructure failures so what do we do
well we run our services in more than
one cluster so we run something called
distributed services a distributed
service is just a kubernetes service
that runs on multiple clusters from an
outsider's perspective it's the same
logical service i don't need to know
that it's running on multiple clusters
so here i have the same service front
end running on four clusters on the left
hand side i have two clusters in region
one in two different zones and on the
right hand side i have two clusters in
region two in two different zones so you
can see that i not only do i have
cluster resiliency i have zonal
redundancy and regional redundancy and
what that means is if my cluster goes
down i still haven't lost my service i
have three other clusters that can serve
traffic for that service i can lose an
entire region and i have not lost that
service i can lose multiple clusters in
multiple region
as long as that last cluster has enough
capacity to serve traffic for that
particular service i'm good to go so you
can already see the effects of
scalability and resiliency when you run
distributed services
well with distributed services comes a
few considerations that you may not
consider in a single cluster life
for example service discovery and
traffic routing in a single cluster
service discovery and traffic routing
are kind of automatic when you drop a
service into a cluster it gets
automatically discovered other services
can get to it routing just works so how
do we do that in a distributed service
environment
here we have two distributed services
what if the front-end service wants to
talk to the cart service how does the
front-end service know which pods are
healthy for the car service which pods
to get to and how to route to those pods
so this is kind of the east-west traffic
problem
next is ingress again in a single
cluster environment we have an ingress
object we deploy the ingress object and
we can get traffic from outside of the
cluster to our service no problem well
how do we do that in a multi-cluster
environment how do we do multi-cluster
ingress
so this is the multi-cluster ingress or
the north-south problem and then when we
bring location into the mix things get a
little bit more complicated here we have
service running on two different regions
let's say region one is in europe and
region two is in asia so the users that
are in europe are closer to region one
we want to deliver their traffic to an
instance of a service that's closer to
them so in europe and likewise for the
users that are in asia we want to
deliver their traffic to an instance of
a service that's running in asia only
when something goes wrong for example
let's say the everything in in the
europe region is down now we want to
send the traffic from european users
over to the asia user so how do we
manage all of that
and then lastly telemetry again in a
single cluster environment we have
implementations and tools where we can
measure logging and tracing and metrics
for every single service how do we do
that in a distributed service which
signals to measure how do we know if a
service is healthy what to alert on so
all of those things we're going to talk
about and we're going to use anto
service mesh to solve some of these
things
so let's go to the demo
let's get oriented to the environment
here i have a google cloud project with
four gke clusters running gke1 and two
are running in region us west two gke
three and four are running in region us
central one so it's the same four
cluster model that we just saw
let's look at the workloads page i've
deployed a few sample applications and
one of them is the famous online
boutique retail application that
consists of 13 services i've deployed
each service in their own namespace and
you can see by the workloads that each
service is deployed as a distributed
service so add is running on all four
clusters cart is running on all four
clusters shop front end which is how you
access the application it's also running
on all four clusters
let's take a closer look at one of these
deployments so we're going to look at
shop front end running in gke1 and i'm
going to look at just the pods for that
particular one
you can see that this pod is running two
containers one is the shop front end
container that's your actual application
container and the other one is the asm
sidecar proxy called the istio proxy now
this proxy governs the flow of traffic
to and from this particular container
and if we look at the configuration of
this proxy we can see what version of
asm we're running so in this case we're
running 1.10.4 which also correlates to
the istio version we can also see that
we're using the google managed mesh ca
as our certificate authority
we can also see that our trust domain is
the workload identity for the project
and i'm using the same trust domain for
all four clusters and that's how
services can talk and trust each other
across clusters
what we want to do is we want to look at
from this istio proxy's perspective how
does it view other services
let's quickly jump into the terminal and
i'm going to go ahead into my gke1
cluster
let's look at the pods so cube control
get pods this is the same pod that we
were just looking at in the console
we're going to use the istio cuddle cli
command and i just want to look at the
proxy config and i just want to look at
the endpoints configuration in the proxy
config for this particular pod and
instead of dumping out the entire config
i'm just going to grip it for one of the
services which is the cart service
and here you can see that from the
perspective of this shop front-end pod
it sees that there are four endpoints
out there that it can access when it
accesses the cart
service
these ip addresses point to the pod ip
addresses of the four endpoints let's
look at the pods
so first thing i'm going to do is look
at the pods in
in the gke1 cluster that's running in
shop cart namespace so shop cart
namespace is where the cart service is
running and you can see that in gk1
cluster i only have one pod running with
the ip address of 10.0.2.11
which is the same ip address that you
see up here
which means that the other three
ip addresses correspond to pods running
in the other three clusters and we can
quickly verify that by just picking one
other cluster for example gke4
and again in gke4 we're also just
running one cart pod with an ip address
of 10.8.2.143
which is the ip address here
so the asm control plane goes out and
discovers the endpoints for every single
service and configures every single
istio proxy with those endpoints and
that's how every single service and
every single pod knows how to get to
every other service so that's how the
service discovery piece is working but
we also want to make sure that the
traffic routing east-west is working so
for example
the front-end
service can talk to the cart service
so in order to demo that it's best done
visually through a dashboard
so here we i have created a custom
dashboard for the cart service
and this dashboard here on the left hand
side i'm looking at the request rates
and i'm i've grouped them by location so
i want to see
who is accessing the cart service from
which location
and from the
legend here you can see that i'm
receiving requests to all four pods
and further i can group this by let's
say a source service source canonical
service
and here you can see that there are only
two services accessing shop cart one is
shop front and the other one is checkout
and both services are accessing all four
locations and you can see that i have a
load generator that's running that's
showing me that the traffic routing is
working so in gke every pod can talk to
every other pod if you have deployed gke
in vpc native mode as long as you have
the appropriate firewall rules so now
east-west traffic is working
next let's take a look at north south
traffic and how ingress works so for
that let's go back to our clusters page
and you'll notice that i have this fifth
cluster called the ingress config
cluster this is the cluster on how i
configured multi-cluster ingress let's
take a closer look at this cluster so
i'm going to go back into my terminal
i'm going to change my context to the
ingress config cluster and change my
name space to istio system
inside of the istio system namespace i
have two resources i have a
multi-cluster ingress resource and i
also have a multi-cluster service
resource and i have multiple
applications and that's why you see a
couple of these
so the multi-cluster ingress resource
corresponds to
a ingress resource and a multi-cluster
service resource corresponds to a
service resource just like you would
normally configure an ingress and a
service
so let's take a closer look at each of
these so i'm going to look at the
multi-cluster
ingress resource first for the online
boutique and you can see that the
multi-cluster ingress resource looks a
lot like an ingress resource so i have a
rule with a host so here's the host of
how i'm going to access this application
and it points back to an app a service
but in this case instead of pointing
back to a kubernetes service it's
pointing back to a multi-cluster service
on port 80.
and then if we look at the multi-cluster
service resource
that corresponds to this again it looks
a lot like a kubernetes service resource
so if we look at especially the spec of
that particular resource you can see
that it has a service name a port
and then most importantly it has this
selector and what it's selecting is the
istio ingress gateway as the back-end
service the only difference here is
these cluster selectors and in this
particular case i've selected all four
clusters so essentially what i've
created is the multi-cluster ingress you
can think of it as the front end that
points back to four different backend
services
that matches this selector which is the
estuary ingress gateway selector
and what that creates if we go back to
the console and i'm going to go to
network services load balancing
is a front end with four back ends
so here if we just look at these top two
as a matter of fact if we look at the
second load balancer which is the online
boutique istio mci that got created when
we created that mci resource
and it gave me a front end and we'll
talk about the certificate here shortly
but more importantly
we have created four backends and these
four back ends are pointing to the istio
ingress gateway services running on all
four clusters and we can verify that by
looking at the zone and you can see that
all four zones are covered
and if we click on any of these
endpoints you can see the actual pod ip
addresses and then they are healthy
if we go back to this this certificate
i've created a google managed
certificate for in a dns name so
remember in the multicluster ingress we
had a host field that pointed to this
dns name and so in order to access this
service i can just simply copy this open
a new tab
paste it
and you can see that we can access our
online boutique application and we can
navigate around this application so here
i'm looking at product description
adding it to the cart here i'm looking
at the cart service i can place the
order which invokes the checkout service
and you can see all the functions are
working for that particular application
the way the actual traffic flow is
working
is when i access this
url if i scroll back i'm going to this
front end ip address from this front end
traffic is being routed to one or more
of these istio ingress gateway back ends
and then the istio ingress gateway back
end routes the traffic to the shop front
end
so the next thing is the implication of
locations
so remember i have istio ingress gateway
running in two different regions in four
different clusters i also have the shop
front end running in both of these
regions in all four clusters so what i
want is if i'm closer to us west two
region i wanna go to the us west tourist
during grass gateway and then eventually
also to the u.s west to shop front ends
so let's take a look at how that is
configured
i'm going to go back into kubernetes
workloads and i have a load generator
running for the online boutique and you
notice that my load generator is only
running in the west two regions and this
is so i can show you locality load
balancing
i also have locality load balancing
configured but only for the shop front
end
application and the reason is just for
this demo purposes
so let's go to the console let's go to
one of the clusters gk1 for example and
i'm going to show you the destination
rule that's running for the shop
front-end
you can configure locality load
balancing mesh wide but i prefer to
configure it on a per service level so
here i've configured it just for the
shop front end and the destination rule
determines how the traffic is routed
once the routing decision is made and
this is where you configure locality
load balancing so here in the load
balancer section you can see that i have
locality load balancing enabled
i also have a failover setting which
says go from us west to region to us
central one since i'm looking at the
gke1 configuration and then i also have
this outlier detection which determines
when a failover or a failure occurs this
is a very aggressive rule just for the
sake of the demo essentially i'm saying
is for in every second even if i have a
single error consider that an outage and
eject that particular deployment for a
minute
and so you can see that just with the
addition of these five ten lines
i've i've created locality load
balancing and i have the same exact
destination rules for all four clusters
for the front end service
so in order to prove that that is
actually working remember that my load
generator is only running in us west 2.
so what i should expect is only the west
front end to be receiving traffic
because nobody else is really accessing
this particular application
so the best way to do that is let's look
at
the charts
so here i'm i have a custom dashboard
that i've created for shop front end
very similar to the one that we were
looking at for cart earlier
again we're looking at the request rates
uh and i've grouped those by locations
so i have the four locations so us west
2ab and central 1ab but you can see that
i'm only receiving traffic for to the
shop front end only in the west regions
and not in the central regions even
though i have pods running in the
central region that means locality load
balancing is working and you can
configure the same locality load
balancing for every single service
so in a sunny day scenario that works
great
everything will go to its closest end
point
but what happens when there is a failure
so my load generator is running in the
west region what happens if the west
region is down i should expect that load
generator to start sending traffic to
the central region because i've
configured the failover rule as such
so let's do that in order to simulate
that all i'm going to do is scale the
replicas for the shop front end in the
west region down to zero
so let's go to the console
and i'm going to run the scale command
and i'm just going to fix this spelling
error so all i'm doing is scaling the
shop front end deployment replicas down
to 0 and gke 1.
as well as in gke2 these are my two
u.s west locations what that's going to
do is render
a failover from us west to region to u.s
central one so we'll wait a few minutes
and see how the charts
do
a few minutes have passed and now you
can see that all of the traffic is
routed to the central servers
so i have not
changed the load generators location
it's still running in us west
but because of the failover from us west
we're now going to central one
the chart to the right is also showing
us error rates by location and you can
see that for the same time that the
failover occurred we did not experience
any errors so it was a seamless failover
and we expect this to kind of go back
when we change the replicas back to one
so let's quickly do that
so we go back to
the console all i'm going to do is rerun
that command but this time change the
replica to one for gk2
and for gke1
we'll wait a few minutes
and now we see that the traffic has gone
back to the us os2 clusters and no more
traffic going to the central clusters so
we're back to our sunny day state of
locality load balancing and again we did
not experience any
errors throughout this
changeover
so this technique is also useful if you
want to perform some scheduled
maintenance on a cluster you can now
manually and explicitly drain clusters
by scaling just the replicas down for
any cluster down to zero and shifting
traffic over to different clusters as
long as there's capacity there and then
you can perform an upgrade or any kind
of maintenance on those clusters
all right the last thing we want to look
at is observability and manageability of
services so for that let's go back to
the cloud console and here we're going
to go to anthos
service mesh
when you have anti-service mesh deployed
on one or more clusters you will get
this dashboard view
this dashboard view gives you a table
view and a topology view for all the
anthos enabled services so here i have
all of my services that are running in
multiple clusters so for example shop
front end is running on four clusters i
can look at which four clusters it's
running on
this comes completely out of the box
without you having to instrument
anything in the application if i click
on shop front and i can get further
information about this service so i can
see inbound and outbound
services that it's talking to i can get
the golden signals
i can look at the metrics for this
particular service
these are canned dashboards again that
come with every single service so you
get these dashboards out of the box so
you get requests per second error rates
latency for the three different
percentiles the 50th 95th and 99th as
well as request size response size cpu
memory and disk for every single service
without having to instrument anything
from here you can also go to application
log so i can just click on application
logs and it will
create the right filters for me so i can
just look at the application logs for
the front end so i can see that you know
i have requests going in and out
i can also look at traces from here so i
can just click on traces if i want to
look at
request trace this is something you do
have to configure in your application
i can look at the histogram
of my
requests coming in
and then i can click on as an individual
request and i can obviously look at that
particular trace information again all
of this is part of the info service mesh
furthermore i can go to health and i can
create slo so here i've created an slo
for latency based slo for
the front-end service
and if i open this up
and if i edit this slo i can just kind
of show you how i created it so the
first thing is i picked latency as my
metric i can either choose availability
or latency i can hit continue
here's the actual signal or the metric
that i'm i'm using which is the response
latencies i can see the historical
response latency and based on that i
just picked a value so here i could see
that there are some spikes above 1500
milliseconds so i just picked one for
1500 milliseconds
you give it the compliance period so i'm
picking calendar day and i'm keeping my
goal at 95 so 95 of the time i want my
latency to be 1500 milliseconds or below
for that particular service if i had
continue it also gives me the json view
of that particular slo so i can use the
slo api to create this if i'd like
and then i just create my slo
so for every single service you can do
that and i recommend you do that for
every single service and you can do that
in your as part of your ci cd pipeline
this is where you'll get your slis and
your error budgets as well as if you've
configured any alerts you can create
alerts by just clicking on
this and you can measure how exactly
your service is being experienced across
the board so we typically recommend at
least creating
two slos for every single service one
for availability and one for latency so
you can see whether your users are
actually able to access your service and
then what is their experience when they
access that particular service
so that's the end of the demo let's go
back to the presentation
a few calls to action first hopefully
it's very obvious run distributed
services never bet your services on your
infrastructure by running your service
on more than one kubernetes clusters
you've immediately gained the advantage
of scale and resiliency
second monitor your distributed services
golden signals is a great place to start
right somebody gave me this analogy that
when you go to the doctor
they don't try to diagnose you for every
single disease right they look at your
symptoms and then they figure out
exactly what's wrong with you so alert
on symptoms not on every single
potential cause in a distributed world
there are thousands and thousands of
signals out there and if you want to
alert on every single time a cpu or
memory spikes you're going to get
overwhelmed
lastly use location as a benefit i see
two main benefits for location
especially if you're running
multi-regional services first is you can
deliver your service closer to your user
right
and secondly thinking about failure
domains so i think of failure domains in
terms of concentric circles for instance
a kubernetes cluster is a failure domain
when a cluster goes down it only takes
down the services that are running on
that cluster a zone is a failure domain
if all the clusters in a zone or the
zone itself goes down then that zone
cannot serve traffic and a region is a
failure domain thinking in those terms
helps you kind of do figure out how to
do maintenance windows and scheduled
operations on your infrastructure if you
want to build distributed services you
can go to this link
bitly
run dash distributed services or you can
pause the video and scan this qr code
that takes you to the same link i thank
you for your time and enjoy the rest of
the conference